thank you for the imitation it's great
to be here with all of you I want to
start off by taking you back to 1995 and
maybe a pleasant trip down memory lane
for some of you and others in the room
may not have been warm at that time but
if we go back to 1995 we were using
Windows 95 on our browser and it was a
cool new thing
Netflix excuse me uh Netscape had just
gone public with their mosaic browser
that's how we were getting around on the
Internet Oh Jay was on trial Jerry
Garcia had just passed away and some of
us were actually working on automated
vehicles but what we were looking at at
the time wasn't what you think about is
an automated vehicle today instead the
concept was an automated Highway we
would have magnets in the road that the
cars would follow and the cars would
follow each other at extremely close
spacing so we can improve capacity and
we can reduce some of the aerodynamic
drag so doing my PhD work at UC Berkeley
I actually worked with a set of Lincoln
Town Cars and my task was to make sure
that these things could drive about two
meters about six feet apart from each
other while the car is accelerated or
even had a heavy break and to make sure
that that distance remained constant now
at the time that was sort of crazy
science fiction and whenever anybody
asked us when do you think this is going
to be realistic we use the typical
answer that people have used for
automated vehicles since about 1940 and
we said 20 years in the future
well now we're a little bit more than
twenty years in the future these things
are still not exactly ready for
primetime but they're darn close you can
see them actually being tested on the
roads around here and we've gotten an
awful lot closer so things have changed
dramatically in that intervening time as
well I've had the opportunity to work
with a whole number of interesting
vehicles and a large number of great
students to try to move this technology
forward and in particular to try to
focus on what we can do to improve
vehicle safety and so what I want to
talk about today is to share some of the
stories of our work that have come
through is we've developed these
automated vehicles but try to turn them
away from just technical lessons and
into a little bit more generalizable
life lessons that could be valuable to
people who are thinking about starting a
venture whether that's a company or
anything else that you want to get
up and running from basically the ground
floor so I'm going to begin with this
part out on the racetrack which is where
we've been spending a lot of time now
this may not make immediate sense to
everybody I've just said we're
interested in vehicle safety and we're
going out to a racetrack which may not
be the first thing that comes to mind
whenever you hear vehicle safety but in
fact human race car drivers are
absolutely amazing at using all of the
friction that's available between the
tire and the road they're trying to use
it to be fast they want to be the first
across the finish line and get there
ahead of other drivers but we thought if
we could learn how they do that we can
use that same capability to be safe to
use all the friction between the tire in
the road to give the vehicle out of
harm's way as expeditiously as possible
and handle situations where I may have
very low limits of what the vehicle can
do because I've hit a patch of black ice
for instance where it started raining so
we went out onto the racetrack and
fortunately we had a sponsor with a
great collection of vintage automobiles
miles Collier now there's a lot of
people that have collections of great
automobiles and not many people will
actually allow grad students to put
funky antennas on the top and measure
what these cars are doing out on the
racetrack but miles was ok with that so
we would go out to the racetrack where
we could test cars like a 1960 Porsche
Abarth Carrera
we could add sensors to this that you
might find more frequently in a modern
Formula One car or modern race car than
you would expect in a vintage vehicle we
can then set up actually a differential
GPS station so that we could measure the
position of the car out on the track to
within about one to two centimeters and
do that several hundred times a second
after that we installed some cameras in
the car so that we can see what the
drivers were doing and then we were
ready to race
the cars would go out on the track with
our sort of makeshift group of sensors
on board and we would wait patiently in
the pits hoping that all the data would
offload properly that nothing had come
loose while the car was out on the track
when it did that was a great feeling of
satisfaction we got all of the data and
then can sit down and debrief with some
of the world's
drivers about what was actually going on
out on the racetrack what were you
thinking at that time what was going
through your head when this happened
with the car and I'll summarize you know
very briefly what we learned from this
we learned a huge amount but what we
found was that a lot of the basic
descriptions that you get of driving a
racecar from books on driving are
actually quite accurate that the task of
driving a racecar around the track boils
down to a couple of different parts the
first of which is the path you take
which racers refer to as the racing line
and the racing line in general what you
want to do is to try to make sure that
the car doesn't have to slow down and so
usually what this means is trying to get
the biggest radius into a turn that you
can and so race car drivers will
naturally approach a turn from the
outside then go to the inside and then
back out to the outside as well so the
car doesn't have to slow down that's
sort of half the trick is finding the
path that you want to take around the
track now the other trick to this is
driving it at the limits of what the car
is capable of doing there's only so much
friction between the tire and the road
now I can use that friction in a number
of different ways I can use it for
braking I can use it for accelerating I
can use it for cornering but I can't
possibly get the maximum braking in the
maximum cornering at the same time so
what I need to do as a racecar driver is
to learn to trade-off among these things
as I travel along my racing line so I'm
going to be hard on the brakes as I come
into the corner I'm gonna roll off of
the brakes as I steer into the corner
I'm going to corner and then I'm gonna
steer out of the turn as I get on the
gas and that's the basic process that
racecar drivers are doing so we thought
okay humans can do this we're gonna take
computers and we're going to solve this
problem because we have math we have as
much math as we want at our disposal so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
and we're gonna find the very best path
around the racetrack we're gonna find
the single best path that we could
possibly take around this racetrack and
then we're gonna drive it pretty close
to what the car is capable of doing and
our expectation was that if we could do
this we're going to be pretty darn
fast so working together with Audi in
the electronics research lab we built up
Shelley Shelley is an Audi TTS which is
mostly stock we made a few modifications
to it we have control of Shelley's
steering acceleration due to the the
throttle also brakes and gear shifting
Shelley has some precise GPS equipment
and a front laser scanner so she can
find her way around the track figure out
the racing line and then change our
braking steering and acceleration
commands to try to act like a real race
car driver and so it's very fun to take
Shelley out on the track and she
basically figures out the same things
that humans do you go to the outside and
then you drop down to the inside of the
turn and then accelerate out to the
outside and when you want Shelley take a
sequence of turns out on the track
you're kind of watching from a distance
marveling and saying what driver looks
like they know what they're doing and
then the car comes around and you look
and you go wait there's no one inside
the car is driving itself but if you do
take a ride actually inside the car you
realize it's kind of chill unless
there's something dramatic that happens
the steering commands and brake commands
and throttle commands that Shelley is
calculating are pretty smooth so we were
pretty happy that we could measure what
human drivers did and we could sort of
put that at least in a rough form into a
car we then decided to ask how good are
we really so we thought we would
challenge somebody now Shelley very
quickly got faster than any of us on the
research team
we're not professional racecar drivers
but all of us have in fact been through
a novice race car training course this
is something that we've proven were
better programmers than we are drivers
because we've programmed the car to be
faster than we are but we decided to
challenge David Vaadin David vaji is the
CEO of the racetrack that we normally
test at Thunderhill Raceway Park in
willows and he's also was Specht Miata
champion so this is a champion amateur
racecar driver who knows the track like
the back of his hand and we thought that
would actually be a good comparison so
what we did was we let David take
Shelley around the track and then we
drove Shelley around the track
and then we decided to do a comparison
of the way that they actually drive the
track which is a pretty fun thing to
look at so what we noticed is that
Shelley takes a different path around
the wide turn to that starts Thunder
Hill Shelley jumps to the inside whereas
David stays to the outside and tries to
build up speed and this puts him in the
head by maybe about a half a second or
so as he comes out of turn two and
starts into this sequence of three four
and five he gets a good jump down the
hill and turned five and Shelley is
still behind by about a half a second
but now Shelley starts to be very
aggressive at some corners there's some
straights that she can accelerate
without the weight of a human and as
they started to get to the back part of
the track what's interesting is that
David has to wander a little bit because
he can't find the mathematically
straight his path
whereas Shelley can so Shelley actually
pulls about even as they go into turn
ten and then as they go into turn 11
David decides to cheat and in fact goes
over the line that we have told Shelley
to stay within this buys the human with
their ingenuity about a half a second
over the car but Shelley outbreaks David
into the very tricky turns 14 and 15
that in the track and pulls even again
then Shelley's weight advantage begins
to take over on the straightaway and she
finishes that particular lap about four
tenths of a second faster than David now
this is a two minute and 17 second lap
and we are within four tenths of a
second of a champion amateur racecar
driver
so we're pretty happy with that in fact
maybe we were a little bit optimistic
about how good we were at that point
because we decided to throw down the
gauntlet to somebody who was a little
bit better junior Hildebrand jr. is an
inny car driver and is actually in
addition to being an idiot car driver is
has a fantastic technical mind he really
understands not only how to drive the
cars but how the cars are set up the
interaction between the technology and
what the driver is doing he's very
understanding of what it is that he's
doing in the car does a lot of coaching
of driving and so we thought okay why
don't we try this against junior well
Jr was faster and what was interesting
is that jr. was faster not just on one
part of the track we didn't have an
advantage over him on one part of the
track and lose it somewhere else he was
faster every winner he was a little bit
faster on every single turn
clearly we were missing something there
was something that the professional
driver had that we didn't have and this
was fascinating to us because this is
what we were really setting out to learn
how do we use as much of the capability
of the car as possible because that
difference which may be measured in
tenths of a second on the racetrack can
actually be inches as I'm trying to make
an emergency maneuver and could be the
difference between a collision happening
and one not happening at all so we
plotted all of the data and we looked at
what JR was doing we looked at what
David was doing and we looked at what
Shelly was doing and in fact there was a
stark difference that really stood out
to us Shelly as we had designed her was
following the exact same path every time
because that's what we figured we needed
to do we found mathematically the best
path and doggone it we were gonna stick
on it neither David nor jr. did that in
fact they took a slightly different path
every time around the racetrack when we
originally looked at this we thought
that was just because they were trying
to get to our ideal path and missing but
we couldn't have been farther from the
truth when in fact they were doing was
pushing the car to its limits and taking
the path that opened up for them at that
moment in time they were prioritizing
always being at the limits of the car
rather than following one specific path
as jr. looked at the data and looked at
what Shelly was doing he told us if
Shelly was a human driver I was coaching
I would tell her she has her priorities
exactly backwards that instead of
focusing on this path in exactly where I
want to go what Shelly should be
focusing on is how to use the friction
between the tire in the road if she
comes into one turn a little bit quickly
she needs to basically swing a little
bit wider keep the speed up and
just if she comes in a little bit slowly
she could make that turn a little bit
sharper it needs to turn earlier but by
following this one path we were kind of
missing that opportunity so as we came
in thinking that we were trying to solve
one mathematical problem we were trying
to find this very best path around the
track and then drive it reasonably well
we found that the best human drivers did
exactly the opposite
they found the physical limits of the
car they pushed the car to its limits
and they took whatever a path was open
to them as they did that and that made
them significantly faster this is a
really interesting result it was an
interesting result from a research
standpoint it's motivated a lot of our
current research to try to figure out
great how do we capture that capability
in the car but it's also something that
after reflection I realized was sort of
a more general way of living life which
is really to think about pushing to the
limits of what's possible
and seeing what paths open up when you
do so a lot of times with startup
companies this is sort of referred to as
the pivot right as you get into the the
market as you actually start to flesh
out your idea you often discover that
this great plan that you had isn't
working quite as well as you think
or maybe the plan is working fine but
there are other opportunities that are
now open to you if you're flexible
enough to take them this is as somebody
who programs automated vehicles this is
the sort of thing that we look at humans
and just marvel at their capability to
be flexible to adapt to sort of take
advantage of these opportunities that
arise for them as opposed to following
the predetermined path and so the lesson
I've really taken from this is to find
the things that we like to do in the lab
find the things that we do well do them
as well as we can but not be worried
about exactly what sequence of events
we're going to be taking in the future
but to be very flexible about what
research path we take based upon what
we've learned in our current path to
adjust to adapt to use that human
flexibility to our advantage so this is
something that I found a lot in life I
like to have a plan a lot of times right
ok I'm going to do this and then I'm
going to do that and then I'm going to
this but in reality if you want to be
fast on the racetrack the plan gets you
into the corner your skills get you out
quickly if you hold on to that plan
you're slow on the racetrack or
potentially in business what I've also
found under a reflection is in fact a
lot of the coolest things I've done in
my life where things that I never
planned to do one of those was going to
Washington DC so I spent 2016 as chief
innovation officer at the US Department
of Transportation I got to work very
closely with secretary Foxx on a variety
of issues that are very important to me
so I got to help write the country's
first automated vehicle policy which is
somebody who's worked on automated
vehicles since the mid 1990s to actually
be able to go to Washington DC and help
with the initial policy was just
absolutely amazing I got to understand
how government agencies work I got to
understand the interplay of how the
executive branch works with Congress and
even how the White House and agencies
have to negotiate to get anything done I
got to understand how the career civil
servants work with political appointees
I got to do innovative classes classes
on innovation and idea generation across
the federal government and I got to work
with a lot of really amazing people in
Washington DC and if there's one
takeaway message that that I learned
from this time it's how phenomenal the
career civil servants who are working in
DC really are
we all have working for us as taxpayers
a really amazing group of people who are
intelligent hardworking and very
motivated to turn out good policy
working in all of our agencies so it's a
great opportunity to work with them for
a year I was not expecting this at all
there was nowhere on my life plan where
I said okay and now this is when I go to
Washington DC and help with automated
vehicle policy I was not expecting a
call to say hey how would you like to
come work at the Department of
Transportation but the work I had done
set me up for that opportunity and I was
able to take advantage of that path that
opened up for me I'm awful glad that I
did because it is actually shaped the
way that I think about automated
vehicles in a very deep way so these are
the sorts of things that I
think are important that we can learn
from the racecar driver this ability to
to seize the opportunity that opens up
in addition of my time in DC this is
sort of how I ended up becoming an
entrepreneur I wasn't actually focused
on I need to start a company now was
always interested in it so actually as
an undergraduate I was in a dual degree
program with mechanical engineering and
entrepreneurial management so the idea
of starting a company had always
appealed to me but I never really had an
idea around which I wanted to to build a
company but then one day actually one of
my PhD graduates came to me and said hey
Chris you know that stuff that you
worked on in your PhD where you had cars
and they were platooning at close
distances to each other I've been doing
a lot of thinking about this and what if
that was applied to trucks so this was
Josh switkes who said the idea for a
company called peloton technology that
could actually put sleep platoon trucks
in order to produce fuel savings it
turns out that if you actually allow
trucks to draft off of each other if you
can electronically control them safely
to decrease the distance you can save
massive amounts of fuel somewhere
between seven and ten percent in each
truck so I was struck by this and I
thought at the time where can I apply my
skillset to actually make a difference
as far as energy consumption is
concerned and I thought this is it this
is a real opportunity that we have here
so Josh said to me hey do you want to be
an advisor to the company and I said
well maybe but do you need a co-founder
and so he said absolutely so we decided
to form this company and the first thing
we produced was a white paper describing
this concept we sent it around to a few
people and we got a call from Peterbilt
& Peterbilt said hey we're pitching some
new ideas to Walmart and the people at
Walmart who buy all of their trucks you
want to come to Denton Texas and pitch
your white paper yes so off we went to
Denton Texas and we had a meeting with
Peterbilt and Walmart to talk about this
idea and the quote that we walked away
from this is that the person responsible
for buying all of Walmart's trucks said
look if you can do what you're talking
about at the price point that you're
talking about your product is a No
brainer we spend far more for far lower
fuel savings and so we walked out of
this meeting like high five this is
awesome all we need to do now is to go
raise some some funding and we are off
to the races here we know that our ideas
has technological merit I mean we've
actually proved this back in my PhD
thesis that you can do this we know that
the companies are excited about it all
we need to do is raise 10 or 20 million
a venture capital and you know we're
often often going so we decided to sort
of schedule our first first meetings
with VCS to do this now again remember
this is 2011
all right so automation wasn't quite the
hot thing it is now we came in and
pitched our ideas to the first group
they're like you know we love the team
you've got a great idea you're awesome
and everything but this isn't quite the
right fit for us like ok that's fine
went on pitch our idea again we really
love the team you've got some great
ideas we're a little concerned about the
government angle it's not really this
space that we're in ok fine
next pitch kind of the same thing then
you know you kind of get to that point
where you're having the founding team
meeting at Starbucks as you try to plot
strategy and you're having this sort of
soul-searching moment of if we're so
awesome how come we don't have any money
and so we sort of realized that actually
venture capitalists despite you know the
the reputation that I had are actually
incredibly polite and so you feel great
about your idea and your team and
everything as you walk out of the
meetings but at the end of the day we
had no money so we thought maybe we need
to downscale our ambitions a little bit
maybe we need to think about a seed
round that'll just allow us to build up
some trucks and get this idea proven and
so as we started to do that we started
to talk to some angel investors and they
actually gave us some some great advice
so we had been sort of pitching this
idea to to VCS trying to get them
excited about fuel savings trying to get
them excited about what we saw as
interest from the from the truck
industry but we weren't quite getting
our argument across and montine win one
of the angel investors who we connected
with said look you need to come at this
from a totally
for direction you really need to talk to
the people in the room and get them
excited about what it is that you're
trying to do here from their perspective
and our pitch went from talking about
trucks and flow fields and the physics
and the fuel savings to one that was
much simpler it revolved around the
number two percent what is two percent
two percent is actually the profit
margin at many large trucking fleets
trucking is a ridiculously brutally
competitive business and so two to three
percent is the profit margin that many
of these large fleets are running fuel
is 30 percent of their expenses if you
save seven percent of fuel you have
effectively doubled the profit margin
with that entry suddenly people
understood what this was about as
opposed to say trucking fleets are
interested in this it became clear that
this is sort of a life-or-death
difference if you can provide this sort
of technology and so with this change in
our message we were in fact able to get
a seed round of funding which led then
to Series A and Series B and now peloton
has a large fleet of trucks out
developing this and it's very close to
commercial launch of a platooning system
putting it in the hands of commercial
fleets to really save large amounts of
fuel on the open road so what's the
lesson here
well I think you know it could be
engineers need to learn to talk business
but I don't think that's actually the
message here and as I reflected on this
it's also not just about pitching to
your audience because you know giving a
talk to an audience is one thing you
know so as I prepared for this what did
I think about well what might be
interesting to this group of people
right I can just sort of explain some
things that I think are interesting to
all of you hopefully I managed to get
that about right but you're not actually
key to my venture right I get to go to
continue to do this stuff in my lab
regardless of your interaction with me
when I'm actually trying to raise
funding when I'm
trying to bring on say other founders or
other members of my team what I really
need to make sure of is that we're
sharing a vision for where this is going
and the lesson that I learned from this
is that if you're going to be successful
in adventure you need people to share
your vision even if they don't share
your motivation so each one of the
founders of our team really had a
different reason for doing this all
right I was doing this not because I
really wanted to build a company but
because I thought this would be a good
outlet for my skill set to make an
impact on energy that's not necessarily
anybody else's motivation involved with
this so the trick here is to basically
make sure that you have harmony around
the vision so everybody's moving in the
same direction but understanding that
everybody may be coming at that from a
very different motivation and I'm
surprised it took me a while to figure
this out because this is basically life
as a faculty member
right I'm raising money for research
what am i raising money for research for
it's I want to educate students I want
to take my students to a racetrack and I
want them to have an amazing engineering
education my corporate sponsors think
that's cool but that's not what's
appealing to them right what's appealing
to them is that this is going to
generate new ideas that are gonna get
into their company that are going to
help them develop better products now
although we have different motivations
we can harmonize around the vision of
where this needs to go and so this is
something that I think is very important
in terms of thinking about it and it's
hard sometimes when we're so passionate
about what we want to do and the reasons
why we want to do it that it's often
easy to overlook the fact that somebody
could be a great Ally for us but their
motivation could be entirely different
from ours and we need to learn to find
that motivation and speak to them and
I'll say in particular one of the things
that has blown me away in this process
is how many people seasoned
entrepreneurs and other people in
Silicon Valley are really interested in
acting as mentors how many people are
out there whose motivation is really to
help and to mentor now if you find one
of those people that's amazing but you
also need to understand where their
advice is coming from and the best thing
that you can do is to let them be a
mentor understand that you're passionate
about your venture they may be
passionate about
mentoring you you can have a shared
vision with that but it's really
important to understand where they're
coming from and not to rebuff that and
say you know I don't really like that
idea
maybe that's fine maybe they don't care
about the idea either what they want is
the interaction and the mentoring these
things are very important because
mentors who have done what you want to
do can be absolutely invaluable in
avoiding mistakes so peloton is now
testing out on the road what's
interesting as we've done this is that
the basic algorithms are not much
changed from my 1995 PhD thesis the sort
of core idea behind this is still pretty
much the same but when you go from
something that runs in a closed
environment to something that runs in
the open road you need to prepare for
every single contingency all the little
things that can go wrong and so actually
moving from the laboratory to a product
involves solving a lot of problems that
you never thought that you were going to
have and that kind of brings up the last
thing that I've learned about problems
that that seem hard or problems that
seem easy as you attempt to tackle them
let me give an example just suppose
somebody should want to create an
automated vehicle the drifts all right a
car that can actually track a path that
can get around while going sideways the
way Formula Drift racers or you know
your average fast and furious movie does
a car that can actually handle in these
extreme situations why would you want to
do that well first aw it's awesome but
actually there's a practical aspect as
well which is that the physics are very
similar to what you would encounter if
you're on ice so if you can actually
control cars that are doing this you
could actually maneuver cars on ice when
human drivers might be spinning out to
actually have them sort of thread the
needle between dangerous situations and
do quite well so let's just suppose one
wanted to create a car like this and
furthermore wanted to do it in a
DeLorean because if you're gonna
actually create an autonomous drifting
car why not do it with style so this is
what we set out to do actually we
decided to build Marty
and autonomous electric drifting
DeLorean with the idea of trying to be
able to control the car under these very
extreme situations to really show the
limits of what we could do to show that
in any situation where a human driver
would become lost would start to veer
from the path or have the car become
unstable that we could actually very
tightly control the car so we built this
and in fact we did develop a car that
can handle under some very extreme
circumstances so without any human input
Marty can actually put himself into a
drift sort of doing donuts around a cone
out in our test track but can also swing
wider and start to navigate through an
obstacle course so while the tires are
producing copious amounts of white smoke
the car can actually slide sort of
sideways between cones come in two
orbits around cones slide through all
the time again without the human having
to do anything at all and so the car is
basically sideways this entire time and
gliding as if it were on ice with the
exception of the large chunks of black
tire getting hurled everywhere as we do
this this is a level of precision that
even the best human drift drivers a
don't achieve so we are able to track
within usually about 10 to 20
centimeters of our desired path while
the vehicle is sideways this entire time
what seems like just a physically
impossible challenge once we work the
physics starts to become easy now not
say this wasn't challenging not to say
this was an excellent work by John Gogh
and some of my other graduate students
but it was a problem that we have solved
we were able to physically understand
how to do this
and then it becomes a problem of math
now if I were to pose that problem to
you it would have first sound pretty
hard whereas there's other problems that
I could solve to you or opposed to you
that might sound pretty easy let's say I
have an automated vehicle and I come
upon a vehicle which is double parked
where it has no business being parked
anybody ever encountered this on the
road
nobody certainly come on all right there
we go
that's the audience-participation moment
there okay so as you're going down the
road and you do this what does a human
driver gonna do well assess that the
situation is safe and decide to overtake
and keep going down the road now the
problem is is if my vehicle is
double-parked and I have a double yellow
line California Vehicle Code says I'm
not supposed to cross that double yellow
line the California Vehicle Code doesn't
actually say you can cross the double
yellow line if there's a car that has no
business being parked in front we're
making a human judgment of this is the
reasonable thing to do we would expect
that the law would back us up that this
is a reasonable thing to do we would
expect that the Highway Patrol would
look at us and say this is a reasonable
thing to do but now I'm programming an
automated vehicle what is my general
rule here I've just ignored one law
because I want to get down the road
faster hmm that doesn't sound very
general there's something about this
circumstance that we as humans think are
okay but now as I started to think about
coding this into an automated vehicle
what if that car actually has somebody
in and they've just come to a temporary
stop what if this car has actually seen
something in front of it and there's a
reason it's stopped there are a lot of
situations that start to arise from this
very very simple scenario of a double
parked vehicle thinking about how I
overtake that is actually a deceptively
difficult problem let's look at another
problem and that's a simple crosswalk as
I look at automated vehicles and I look
at the way that they sense the world a
lot of automated vehicles will use laser
scanners to sense the world anything
very close to the laser scanner is seen
in a lot of detail as it starts to get
further away the laser scanner has much
less detail it may only get a couple of
reflections so I have some idea that an
object is there but I don't see it very
clearly and in fact the laser scanner is
while they give this wonderful
360-degree field of view close in to the
vehicle are not
same capacity as a human eye when
looking at objects in the distance so
now let's say I'm in a vehicle it's
using laser scanners to scan the
environment and it approaches a
crosswalk it sees something which may or
may not be a pedestrian now to the human
eye we know whether or not that's a
pedestrian but it takes a while for it
to come in focus to the vehicle the
vehicle is looking at all of these
reflections trying to understand is that
pedestrian going to jump into the road
or are they not going to jump into the
road how do I handle this situation now
I don't mean to say that there aren't
solutions to this there are automated
vehicles out on the road that have
solutions to this problem but the
solutions to this problem are actually
sort of fiendishly complicated because
you think about it well what am I going
to do as an automated vehicle
manufacturer I'm probably just going to
slow down if I think there's any chance
of a pedestrian there and I'm gonna play
this really conservatively because I
want to be safe but I've made a decision
there which has an impact on a lot of
different people I've made an impact on
all of the traffic around me if I choose
to slow down the car much more than a
human driver would slow I have to ask
myself is that because human drivers are
being unsafe or is my vehicle somewhat
myopic in its vision and driving
conservatively as a result of that am i
negatively impacting all these other
people on the road who now have a longer
route to work because the automated
vehicles are sort of preemptively
braking for these crosswalks and these
poor saps and the other vehicles don't
just sit back in their automated vehicle
and you know surf the internet watch cat
videos or whatever one wants to do in an
automated vehicle right all of these
things have very very strong
interactions with other road users if
you think about automated vehicles going
out into the world in fact many of us
will have our first interactions with
them not actually driving in the car but
being a pedestrian or being a bicyclist
or being a car in the lane next to these
other vehicles and the way they drive
with us will have really strong impacts
on traffic flow on public acceptance on
all of these other issues so what seems
like a trivial problem
something that we solve as humans
everyday you know approaching crosswalks
and figuring out do I slow down and if
so how much when I start to actually put
that into automated vehicles and I end
up with a whole host of questions and
every question I answer or possible
answer I come up with opens up a few
more you can say for instance well why
don't I just learn what humans do we've
solved this problem so we'll just look
at a bunch of humans and we'll program
the automated vehicle to do exactly what
humans do that could work in some ways
but the challenge is is don't we want
automated vehicles to be better don't we
want them to have fewer accidents than
humans and what do we do about the fact
that humans have some negative aspects
of the way they approach intersections
people have found age biases in whether
or not people will slow down people have
found racial differences in whether or
not people stop at intersections do we
want to encode automated vehicles with
the worst aspects of humanity or do we
in fact want to be better in some ways
if so how do we do that
so the sort of takeaway message that
I've found from working on all of these
things is that sometimes the problems
that seem easy are actually really
really hard they go outside of
engineering and touch on many other
issues in society oftentimes things that
we don't train our engineers to be able
to understand and handle and sometimes
problems that seem hard are actually
very very easy now some of you may be
better at judging these than I am but
I've found throughout my career that I'm
often at the beginning of a project a
very bad judge of whether something is
going to be hard or easy
I find myself continually surprised by
this and the only way that I learn is to
get right into the middle of the problem
and so as you think about this as you
think about ventures that you want to
launch is you think about things that
you want to do in your life I suspect
you may find this to be similar you can
plan all you want you can think about
what's gonna be hard and what's going to
be easy but when you're right in the
middle of it I suspect it's gonna look
very different things that really seemed
like it would be hard to do like our
drifting DeLorean were things that we
were able to actually do in a few years
things that seemed really trivial like
how do I approach a crosswalk and how do
I
have respect for other road users in
this environment are actually really
difficult to come up with a common
answer for in really challenging so
hopefully these are some points that a
relate to fun stories about automated
vehicles but but also resonate a little
bit and give you just a little bit of a
perspective as you sort of approach
things that you want to do to ask a
little bit of you know am i adhering to
this path that I planned out a long time
ago or am I actually being flexible
enough to take advantage of the
opportunities that are opening up you
know am i presenting the car into the
corner and then as they say in racing
going where the car wants to go or am I
trying to kind of continually force my
will about again
excuse me upon something and not take
advantage of what has changed in my
environment how do I get other people on
board with me can I accept the fact that
people are gonna have very different
motivations than I have and while I may
be passionate about something I need to
work with other people who may have
completely other passions but we can
often find a common vision that moves
those things forward and finally with
all these things it makes sense to get
right into the middle of a problem
because when you're in the middle of a
problem is when you understand it when
you're in the middle of a problem is
when you will figure out what's hard
about this and what's easy and where you
want to put your resources do you want
to go after the really hard problems or
do you want to take a slightly different
tact that avoids them you know as
researchers we often go after the hard
problems because we can do that for
research from a company standpoint and a
start-up company standpoint in
particular when you see the cash balance
decreasing every month you know
oftentimes it's best to steer a path
around some of the hard problems towards
things that seem much more doable in the
short term but knowing which is which is
tough and figuring that out
in my experience has only been something
that we've been able to do when we're
right in the middle of the problem so
hopefully these have provided a little
bit of insight what we've learned from
automated vehicles and how that sort of
impacted my decisions hopefully it's
useful to you and I'd love to spend the
rest of the time with any questions you
might have
[Applause]
okay okay so automated vehicles when
will they be on the road and when what
are the potential unintended
consequences so I think automated
vehicles are already on the road and so
you see companies like whammo like uber
like lyft GM actually testing
increasingly on the roads and getting
increasingly farther away from having a
safety driver directly in the cockpit so
in some of the way mo test they've now
been moving the safety driver into the
backseat too and have talked about in
the near future removing the safety
driver entirely at that point we have
fully automated transportation now I
think one of the things that people
think about is in their mind that I'm
gonna buy an automated vehicle and it
has to handle every drive that I take
but in reality the quickest path to
market and the one that makes the most
sense is to think about a vehicle that
can serve a very local area something
that has is able to go over routes that
are of relevance to enough people to
sort of make that operable and maybe it
doesn't work in bad weather so maybe I
send a human driven vehicle to come pick
you up when I need to do that and when
not I send an automated vehicle at a
fraction of the cost so I think what
we're talking about is actually a matter
of you know months to low numbers of
years a lot of companies are talking
about 2019 2020 and I suspect that
you'll see some of it before them as
well now this won't be a vehicle that
you can pop in anywhere in the country
hit a button and have it drive you to
another part of the country but if you
think about it public transportation
doesn't work that way it's all fixed
routes and this will be in fact more
flexible than that so I think the answer
is very very soon but maybe in a more
limited sense than people
we think about what are the unintended
consequences so this is one that I I
enjoy playing around with a little bit
because if you work through the math
about how much transportation needs to
cost or could cost per mile let's say
that I have developed my software for an
automated vehicle I can now replicate
that with with very low incremental cost
I have electric vehicles I use some
shared mobility I can in fact move
people around town potentially for about
10 cents a mile or so and what are a
magnitude cheaper than I do today okay
so if you want an idea about where our
ventures may be in the future
play that out a little bit what happens
when transportation costs for
individuals drop by a factor of 10 hmm
suddenly now the cost associated with
moving people or potentially the cost
associated with moving spaces changes a
lot that could have a huge negative
consequence right as something becomes
much cheaper I'm gonna want to consume
more of it maybe I actually don't bring
people to places maybe I just send rooms
to people because I can move that around
maybe actually transportation at this
point is provided for free so long as I
can actually get the data of where
you're going
maybe data actually becomes the gold of
the gold rush and not mobility in some
ways maybe actually what I will even pay
you to go somewhere if I can kind of
curate that experience that you're
getting in your automated vehicle with
whoever the advertiser is you know
forget you know clicks if you look at
cost per clicks well imagine instead of
like having somebody click on their home
computer see what people are willing to
pay for that think about 10 cents a mile
transportation people could provide free
rides to give you a much more immersive
experience with advertising I think
there's all sorts of different places
that this could go and I think those
will have either positive or negative
consequences so I think it's a great
exercise to sort of play out what are
the industries that are relying on these
transportation barriers or in fact
profiting from this and how will this
reshape our world let's see yes
work on Paul how do you think automation
and specifically in the trucking
industry is gonna affect the economy in
people's jobs great so as so many who's
worked on the policy side what about the
the impact on jobs and in particular in
trucking what's interesting is that
trucking is often used as an example of
where we're gonna expect huge job
impacts the interesting thing is is that
there's a shortage of truck drivers
right now
we have in fact a truck and trailer
combination which we can use to get all
of our vehicles up to the track at once
and we're having the darndest time
hiring somebody to actually drive that
truck there's a very interesting
demographic wave in truck drivers and at
private fleets I think the average age
of truck drivers is about 53 that's
average there are more truck drivers 65
and older than there are truck drivers
21 to 25 in the US so there's this sort
of big demographic bubble that's moving
through I suspect the people who are in
that demographic wave will have a job
driving a truck really as long as they
want to have a job driving a truck
because there will be those those
opportunities available trucking has not
been able to get younger people into it
and so I think what you're gonna see is
is that that demographic wave may move
through it and not be replaced I think
so that's trucking so I think it's
interesting that people use that as as
an example I do think that artificial
intelligence I do think that automated
vehicles are going to displace a lot of
employment overall it will create some
new opportunities for for maintenance
for understanding logistics of some of
this but I think it is going to displace
a lot of jobs and I think from a policy
perspective this really is a
conversation that we need to be having
because you know we sort of built our
system right now on the idea that you
can contribute your labor and expect a
reasonable day's wage in return and our
society is kind of built on that pillar
the question is if that starts to not be
true because so many of the jobs or the
tasks that we need can be automated then
how are we going to restructure around
that and so I don't have the answer to
that but I think it's I'm glad that
you're asking the question because I
think that's exactly the dialogue we
need to have let's see yes
so one of the things that I find is
interesting is that they'll you know
they will oh great so what about the
public perception aspects of this and
people often have irrational fears of
safety for instance thinking more about
dying in an airplane crash which which
nobody did in a commercial airline last
year there was not a single fatality in
commercial aviation last year versus
thinking about the risk when you get
into a car
where in fact over 45,000 people lost
their lives so how do we deal with this
with automated vehicles and from a
communication standpoint I think it's
very interesting that a lot of times
there are interviews with people about
how do you feel about automated vehicles
and people will report that you know 77
percent of people or have have this
concern about automated vehicles but but
what is their basis of reference you
know what if they know about automated
vehicles what have they learned it's
something that they've read it's
something that they've seen people tend
to be hesitant at first we've seen this
with our cars people often are unwilling
to get in at first they're a little bit
hesitant and then even with the race
cars you know after a couple laps on the
track people are like relaxing yeah cars
got it like you know you do know this
was programmed by like grad students and
a professor and you know the fact that
you've actually safely made it around
the track twice doesn't really imply
that you're gonna continue to make it
around this area safely but people
people's fears go away super quickly so
I think that's also irrational
but but but helpful in terms of people
wanting to have automated vehicles out
there so what I really think is gonna be
key and one of the messages that I've
been giving to manufacturers is that the
very first pilot deployments the very
first vehicles that are carrying people
around are going to set people's
expectations for this technology and so
I think companies should be really smart
to think about what is it that they're
doing with these initial deployments who
are they moving because if there are and
there will be accidents with automated
vehicles I think
we'll look at that and say well do I see
this as as something which is only
available to a small percentage of the
population or do I see this as a
technology which maybe not today but in
the next few years will be available to
me or will be helping my aging parents
move around and that sort of connection
will be really important I think in
building public support so I think I
think it's not a question of going out
to the public and trying to convince
people that these cars are safe and that
they should like them I think it's
incumbent upon the manufacturers to
produce something which is safe which
interacts with the public in a good way
and in fact is available to a large
segment if not all of our population and
I think if they do that then the public
perception issue will be much less than
the people commonly think I you know you
have a lot of people now saying a lot of
the companies are developing this are
are really making the claim that ok we
understand if we're developing the
software for this that we have liability
for the for the software or functioning
I think one of the interesting questions
is when you start to get into the
liability question right now we think
about driving situations and and how the
law handles people whereas if we have an
automated vehicle that has a crash is
that a product liability case at which
point product liability law and traffic
law are really different aspects of the
law and how you can sort of go back and
forth between the two of them is an
interesting question actually when I'm
working with a student in the law school
on that question at the moment so I
don't I don't have an answer for that
but understanding the different parts of
of the law and how they might apply is a
pretty fascinating question let's go
over is there there were no hands over
here coming back down
so the automotive industry is very very
competitive space and it seems like a
lot of major games that you realize are
from things like as you say convoying or
you see that there kind of cooperation
between manufacturers it's gonna be
necessary to make this system to work is
that happening now is that gonna have to
be a policy good question so the
question being they given that how
competitive the automotive space in the
automotive industry is can we get to a
level of cooperation that that might we
might need down the road in terms of
standardization this is something that
government will lead or how do we how do
we get there I do think that there is a
lot of competition but a lot of these
questions about you know how do we
establish for instance that automated
vehicles are doing a good job we have
metrics right now around safety of
vehicles but these are largely
fatalities and measuring fatalities is
not really the best way to go about
understanding whether a vehicle is safe
or not because we have to wait until
something horrendous happens to have any
measure of that so there's a discussion
right now about well what would be other
measures in that discussion for instance
is one that involves government and
involves different manufacturers and so
I think talking about some of these
issues is something that the
manufacturers are willing to do as as a
group interestingly enough there there
was recently an issue in Germany where
in fact the the German auto
manufacturers were accused by one of the
government agencies of acting as a
cartel because they got together to
share technical information and their
argument back was essentially the point
that you made is how are we going to
move into this future where we've got
these sort of intermix vehicles if we
don't share information with each other
so so there really is it interesting and
interesting sort of balance there where
I think there is a willingness to work
together obviously people don't want to
give up their competitive advantages and
sometimes it can be really hard to work
together particularly in the in the
presence of government regulators or
agencies sometimes yeah
if you just program a cartoon to vehicle
to behave in a certain way based on all
whether you have to use artificial
intelligence which allows the situation
so you turn your vision on you yeah so
the question is there's a difference
between whether I program vehicles
explicitly to do certain things where I
use artificial intelligence to let the
vehicle learn now one of the things to
understand about artificial intelligence
is it really is essentially a form of
pattern matching right so basically the
you feed training sets of data into a
neural network and it learns the outputs
from that and then when faced with
something different
essentially matches that pattern and
takes takes the appropriate action now
one of the difficulties with this
particularly from a regulatory
standpoint is that if you introduce new
information you don't quite know what
the neural network is going to do when
you take a more mathematical approach
you can pretty much have a good idea of
well these are the inputs they're gonna
result in these outputs these are the
sorts of things that can mess it up on
the other hand that approach really
doesn't take advantage of the huge
amount of data that you're bringing in
and so I think really a merger of these
ideas is where we're going to find
ourselves going forward where you have
certain things that you may want to
prescribe there may be certain things
that because of the law or because of
certain standards we really want to tell
the car how to behave in a certain
situation there's others where we'd like
to be much more adaptive and match these
patterns I think one thing that that's
interesting to see Google recently
released some stickers that you can put
in images and it totally blows up neural
networks that are doing image
recognition and and so it's a really
interesting example of you have this
neural network which in general does a
fantastic job but a malicious actor with
a little bit of knowledge can cause it
to do entirely the wrong thing
and so those are things that we have to
be a little a little cautious about I
think there can be a great sort of
merger of these two fields but honestly
within academia a lot of times learning
and model-based approaches are almost
different religions in some ways and so
what we've been trying to do is to sort
of figure out where are the interesting
intersections and how can these
technologies play together Wow please
join me in thanking Chris Cody
[Applause]
you